Speaker 1: One of my concerns when it comes
to the Kyle Rittenhouse trial has been that
whatever the legal outcome, the right wing
media is going to make this kid a hero or
a martyr.
And what I mean by that is if he's acquitted,
he will be made a hero and it will be a bellwether
example of how you can choose to go out and
be an armed vigilante, even if you've got
the gun illegally.
You can create a situation in which you end
up fearing for your life, not denying.
Maybe he did, right?
You create a situation and you go free.
And he is going to, if he is acquitted, be
held up as a hero by the right when in reality
this is a failure of parenting, it's a failure
of culture, it's a failure of so many different
things.
If he's found guilty on any of the counts,
he does, any jail time, whatever, he will
be then seen as a martyr.
And the problem here is thinking that he did
something good.
He shouldn't have been there.
He was carrying the gun illegally after killing
one person.
He didn't even try to leave.
He ended up killing a second person and shooting
a third person.
So, of course, in the Lion is Asian of Kyle
Rittenhouse.
Right in the middle of the trial, Sean Hannity
decides to interview the mom, Wendy Rittenhouse.
She agrees to go on Fox News, and it's as
bad as you can imagine.
Let's just start somewhere.
The topic of white supremacy comes up, and
Sean Hannity says, I've seen no evidence at
all that would suggest he's even maybe a white
supremacist.
Let's take a look at that.
Speaker 3: When the then candidate, now president
of the United States and other elected officials
that don't know anything about your son refer
to him as a white supremacist, I have yet
to see any evidence whatsoever that he is
such a person.
Speaker 1: Now, I don't know if Kyle Rittenhouse
is a white supremacist.
I've not mentioned it during the trial, and
I just don't know.
But Kyle Rittenhouse was photographed at a
bar holding up that upside down OK symbol,
now often associated with white supremacy,
so it might not be definitive, may not be
definitive evidence.
But Hannity saying there is no evidence is
a very weak comment.
Part of the This kid's a victim.
He's a great kid.
All of his beliefs are great and he's a hero
for what he did with the guns.
Kyle Rittenhouse Rittenhouse, his mom, by
the way, is a big fan of the judge.
Now, it's not a big surprise for those saying
the judge has just called balls and strikes
and isn't helping one side or the other.
If the mom felt the judge was not useful to
them, she would not be saying The judge is
great.
OK, so big surprise she likes the judge.
Take a look.
Speaker 5: The judge is very fair.
People that I talked to that lives in Kenosha,
all their lives.
They told me that Judge Schroeder is a very
fair judge and he doesn't allow no nonsense
in his courtroom.
Speaker 1: Not a surprise, not a surprise.
The judge's decisions have been to the extent
that he's a factor at the trial.
His decisions have been mostly good for the
defense.
Then the topic came up of when Kyle Rittenhouse
was being directly examined by his own defense
attorneys.
He started crying.
The images in the video have gone viral.
I have not commented on was it real or not?
Were the tears real?
Was it staged?
What?
I've no idea.
She says.
Well, he was.
She was heartbroken by that.
Speaker 3: That's your son.
How did that make you feel?
Speaker 5: It just I just broke down with
with cow crying like that.
It made me feel heartbroken, sad.
And I wanted to just go up there and just
hug him and tell him it would be OK.
Speaker 1: This is part of turning the kid
into a hero.
We're turning the kid into a victim.
That's part of it.
Here is the real cherry on top.
Would Kyle do it all over again in the same
way, and his mom says he probably would
Speaker 3: have you and your son discussed?
Whether or not, if he had to do it over again,
he would go into a situation like that.
Speaker 5: With Kyle, I know him, and you
probably would do it again because that's
the type of person he is,
Speaker 1: not even an I would encourage him
not to go even if it's self-defense.
This is a tragedy to be avoided at all costs.
Two people are dead.
It has ruined our lives.
Look at what we are now embroiled in.
I would tell them not to go, Kyle.
Yeah, he'd probably do it again.
They've learned nothing.
It's not like he went and saved 10 people,
so it was worth it.
It's not like he went and through his providing
medical as he was supposedly there to do.
People survived.
Who wouldn't if it's he?
He just went and people died, and now he's
in the middle of a trial and he would do it
all again.
Sadly, I think she's right.
That's the saddest thing.
And you know, the right loves to talk about
the importance of parenting.
This is a total parenting failure.
And the interview is proof of that.
Now one last thing I want to say about the
mom, and I want to say it carefully.
There are people who have written to me and
they said, David, the mom isn't cognitively
there.
If you listen to the interviews and the way
she talks and you see her presence in the
courtroom, some that she's disabled cognitively,
and everybody should give her a break.
I don't know where people are getting that.
I don't I. I researched it because eight or
10 people wrote to me about that.
Is it her appearance that you're basing that
on?
I found nothing about the mom being cognitively
limited in any way.
I don't know if the comments are classist
in some way.
I have no idea what her level of education
is.
I believe she's a nurse, so to some degree,
she's she's educated.
I don't know anything about that.
And for me, it's not playing a role in analyzing
the things that she's saying.
So there's the interview with the mom not
particularly surprising as far as the content,
and we'll have some of these clips on our
Instagram at David Pakman show where you can
also comment and let me know what you think
of that interview